- Hey Siri.
Hey Siri.
Hey Siri, Siri, Siri.
- I'm sorry, I didn't quite catch that.
- Do you know where I put my car keys?
- Sorry, I'm having trouble
with our connection.
Please try again in a moment.
- So, how do I look?
- I'd rather not say.
- Siri, find me directions
- Sorry, I didn't catch that.
- Find me directions
- Sorry, I didn't catch that
- (sighs)
- Find
- Sorry
- I, ah, uh, ah, huh?
- I, eh, wah, ah, wha?
- No.
- No?
- Can you run the numbers on that report?
- You have no real friends.
- Wait, what?
- Do I have any parties
to go to this weekend?
- Here's what I found on the web
for "to have any parties
to go to this weekend."
- No, do I have any
parties on my calendar?
- Your calendar is as
empty as my cold dark soul.
- Text Mom "I love you and I miss you"
- Here's your message for your boss, Ron,
"I love you and I want
to have sex with you"
Would you like me to send?
- No, no, not Ron
Mom, send it to Mom.
- Okay, sending to Mom,
"I love you and I want
to have sex with you."
Ooowhoop.
- No, delete Siri, delete.
- I already sent the ooowhoop.
- You're fired, Siri.
You're so incompetent.
- Oh, that doesn't sound good.
- I hate you Siri.
- Well, I'm still here for you.
- I don't want you to be here for me.
- Okay.
- No, wait.
Don't leave.
Open Instagram.
I want to see Instagram Siri.
I love you Siri.
- You are the wind beneath my wings.
- It's here, it's here.
- [Group] It's here.
- It's here, get it.
- Get it, get it.
- There.
- I think they got it, get it.
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here.